seit monaten schon beschäftige ich mich
mit den corona schuld wäre der pandemie
wurden milliarden an schulden
aufgenommen ganz genau weiß eigentlich
keiner wie viel geld hat und das jetzt
alles gekostet die masken die impfstoffe
und natürlich auch die restaurants
schließung 1,3 billionen steht dann über
dem artikel in der headline das ist aber
eigentlich gar nicht das was wir schon
aufgenommen haben weil das dass im pc
rücklagen sie merken es ist ziemlich
diffus aber wie kann ich beurteilen ob
olaf scholz ein guter finanzminister war
wenn ich die sachlage nicht mals
verstehe wie kann ich beurteilen ob
meine regierung gut gewirtschaftet hat
wenn ich nicht mal verstehe wie viel
geld aufgenommen wurde wofür was
ausgegeben wurde wurden die masken
richtig eingekauft zum fairen preis oder
nicht hätten die restaurants solange
schließen müssen verstehen sie mich
nicht falsch ich fand die hilfen für die
restaurants richtig aber hätte es so
lange sein müssen wie kann ich also als
bürger jetzt entscheiden ob olaf scholz
einfach nur den weihnachtsmann gespielt
hat die spendierhosen offen hatte
gemeinsam mit der regierung oder ob es
alles richtig war und dass beschäftigt
nicht sehr stark ich fordere von der
regierung die korona rechnung man kann
auch sagen die regierungs
leistungsbilanz denn der stark ist der
dienstleister für uns bürger und wir
müssen verstehen können was mit dem
steuergeld die letzten jahre passiert
ist während der kommune abhandeln jena
absolut richtig würde dir vollkommen
zustimmen es muss eine rechnung am ende
geben nach der pandemie am besten
eigentlich noch vor der bundestagswahl
das wird schwer weil wir uns ja in
gewisser weise immer noch in dieser
pandemie befinden es gibt eine zahl habe
ich heute noch mal nachgeschaut die
vielleicht so ein bisschen zeigt dass
diese corona pandemie bisher jeden
einzelnen bürger gekostet hat und man
kann das ein bisschen überschlagen wenn
man sich anschaut wie der bund in den
letzten jahren also gerade im letzten
jahr auch in diesem jahr die
verschuldung steigert also durch neue
kredite und auch im nächsten jahr
ungefähr noch mal 100 milliarden euro
zusätzlich obendrauf kommen soll und da
kann man feststellen dass pro kopf in
deutschland jeder bürger ungefähr 5000
euro zusätzlich an schulden aufgenommen
hat und das ist nur die bundesleitung
sind die länder und die kommunen noch
gar nicht mehr drin also man kann sagen
corona hat bis jetzt jeden bundesbürger
oder die hilfe die wir auch gegeben
haben rund 5000 euro pro kopf gekostet
aber belehrt mich bin ich da bin
ist es nicht tatsächlich so dass dieses
stabilitäts disziplin von der regale
spricht schon vor 30 40 jahren
aufgegeben worden ist schon also die
staatsverschuldung steigt glaube ich
seitdem mitte der 80er steil an jeder
bundeskanzler nach dem anderen hat er
hat das immer wieder diesen
stabilitätsversprechen gebrochen ist gab
doch mal diese diese schwelle von 60
prozent darf man nicht über
überschreiten des bundespolitischen sind
wir glaube ich bei 80 9 aber das was wir
jetzt gesehen haben war schon extrem das
hat es noch nie gegeben alles hat ist
übrigens das seit dem krieg also seit
1945 wurde noch nie für ein ziel für
eine bewältigung so viel geld genommen
haben jetzt seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
gab es diese lage 21 diesen zweiten
weltkrieg gab es auch noch nie so eine
lage wir haben ja noch nie weltweit eine
solche pandemie gab jemand ich erinnere
mich noch an die autofreien sonntage wo
wegen der ölkrise als es der ölhahn
zugedreht wurde wie sonntags nicht auf
die autobahnen durften das war ein
weltereignis da es gab es einmal in die
wir in der woche für vielleicht 4 6
wochen lang jetzt hatten wir lockdown
uns mit allen möglichen verboten und zu
bewegen aus dem haus zu bewegen oder mit
mehreren freunden zu treffen über monate
hinweg die wirtschaft stand in den
ersten wochen der pandemie auch komplett
still bevor man angefangen hat die
wieder anzufahren und da muss ich sagen
5000 euro so eine rechnung braucht nur
das ist richtig aber 5000 euro für einen
jeden muss man sagen gut investiert ist
aber deswegen war auch mein fokus auf
der leistungsbilanz nicht nur auf die
rechnung was uns gekostet hat obwohl du
hast genau was ich am anfang erklärt
habe wie gut du diese zusammenhänge
erklären ganz hast du direkt unter
beweis gestellt aber ich frage mich und
bela du warst regierungssprecher also
näher an der politik dran geht's kaum
kannst du heute hier beurteilen für
unsere zuschauer ob herr scholz dem
guten job gemacht hat was das geld
betrifft ob die regierung guten job
gemacht hat ich habe mich wirklich
redlich bemüht als journalistin weil ich
das auch als unsere aufgabe sie ich kann
heute nicht vielleicht kann sie an als
politikchef der auch mein chef ist aber
die frage ist doch haben wir also hat
die regierung gut mit unseren finanzen
gehaushaltet oder war es wie
weihnachtsmann geld um sich werfen ich
will eine antwort darauf ich bin eine
leistungsbeurteilung haben haben sie gut
gewirtschaftet ich hatte so ein erlebnis
tatsächlich vor wenigen dabei der lok da
noch härter
restaurants begannen gerade wieder
auszumachen ist dann vom kleinen
italiener in der nähe von münchen
wirklich so ein kleines dorf da stand
vor der die beiden wirte stand vor der
tür kommt der alte dame sagt mensch wie
geht's uns noch nie gut
weil wir in deutschland wohnen also
verglichen mit dem was die zu hause
gehabt hätten wo sie jetzt hier kommen
wir wissen die italiener kommen also
italienische restaurants kommen manche
auch die wird aus kroatien sonst wäre ja
aber ich denke sie waren italiener haben
sie hier viel mehr gab denn es zeigt ein
bisschen wie das bewusstsein ich glaube
wenn wir ehrlich drauf gucken weil das
eine bisher nie dagewesene krise und wir
brauchen wir da nie in die diskussion
mit rein weil sie beraten ja auch dem
österreichischen
kurz und dann könnt ihr auch im
ländervergleich machen wer hat
eigentlich am besten gewirtschaftet wie
würden sie denn die lage sehen was das
geld betrifft müssten die bürger der
mehr transparenz kriegen also in
österreich ist mit deutschland überhaupt
nicht vergleichbar wenn man sich die
politik an guckt es ist so viel schwerer
da wirklich etwas zu verheimlichen und
nicht kontrolliert zu werden also die
kontrollfunktion sind ganz anderer
wir reden aber jetzt über deutschland
wir haben jetzt hier
politiker gerade auto scholz oder sparen
und konsorten die echt jetzt gerade in
der krise sehr viel verbockt haben
glauben wir wirklich dass mit der
nächsten wahl die
wieder solche positionen haben und die
es auf jeden fall verhindern werden dass
es eine lückenlose aufklärung gibt
glauben wir wirklich das es jemals so
wir alles erfahren werden was ist
letztendlich gekostet hat ich bezweifle
dass ich bin ich bin nicht mehr so
optimistisch wie ich es früher war in
dem punkt lena macht eigentlich ganz gut
das sollte eigentlich ne billige jede
regierung sagen jede regierung sollte am
ende einer legislatur einen
rechenschaftsbericht ablegen wie das
übrigens
vorstandsvorsitzende ja auch machen
müssen ganz klar zu sagen was haben wir
eigentlich für unser geld an richtigen
möglich aus sicht der regierung
richtigen dinge getan was war falsch der
mich stört eines in der politik
politiker bundeskanzlerin bundeskanzler
minister stehen sich ja gerne hin auch
kommunalpolitikern sagen ja wir haben
was gemacht also zwei milliarden mehr
für die familien eine milliarde mehr für
die kitas
dann für die straßen noch einmal 30
milliarden mehr gab es eigentlich schon
mal ein politiker der gesagt hat danke
liebe steuerzahler dass ihn das
ermöglicht hat mir fehlt der dank der
politiker an den steuerzahler zu sagen
danke oder ist es gar nicht
gibt es meinen job machen es fehlt ja
dank und das stört mir deswegen dabei
ist so eine rechenschaftsbericht absolut
richtig absolut notwendig um einmal zu
dokumentieren haben wir mit dem geld
dingen die uns unseren job eigentlich
ermöglichen ordentlich gewirtschaftet
oder haben es nicht dann könnte sogar
noch weiter gehen und ich kann das mal
ganz spannend da war ich in diesen
aufsichtsratssitzungen dann sind sie da
die ceo's dann sind da die anleger die
aktien innehaben das war bei der telekom
war ich damals war ich wohl und ihre
schwester tag und dann sitzen da die
bosse und vor ihnen die aktionäre die
dann fragen stellen können und da geht's
auch manchmal herangeschoben wie toll
wäre es denn wenn wir eine regierungs
leistungsbilanz hätten und im publikum
dürfen bürger sitzen müsste man
wahrscheinlich per los machen und sie
müssten beantworten was mit dem
steuergeld passiert ist es wäre
natürlich nur ein kleiner tropfen aber
das bewusstsein was du angesprochen das
würde es doch stärken zu sagen wir sind
die steuerzahler ihr seid unsere
dienstleistung leser -redaktion
vielleicht machen frank ochse und dann
ich finde du solltest unbedingt dabei am
ende den ist im plenum geben wird sollte
dann müsstest du ganz vorne sein tolle
idee aber es zeigt ja auch in
unternehmen ist dann der gesamte
vorstand und das stört mich auch so ein
bisschen ist ja nicht nur der
finanzminister denn das geld verteilt da
hinstellen und sagen ich habe mir großes
getan aber natürlich weiß der das geld
den ressorts zu und die müssen genauso
rechenschaft ablegen war das richtig mit
den masken weil es vielleicht ein
bisschen vorschnell konnten wir nicht
anders sind wohl hinters licht geführt
worden das gesundheitsministerium oder
wer auch immer und dann sagen okay das
haben wir bekommen so haben wir das geld
eingesetzt und so will ist vielleicht
auch für schritt gegangen also tun hier
ist die die auch wenn die mist bauen und
es nachher zu geben da es schief
gelaufen es gibt ja keine kontrollen
keine köpfe in unternehmen rollen katze
punkt so müsste es doch eigentlich
laufen wenn politiker mist gebaut hat
wenn er unser geld verschleudert hat
wenn er uns wirklich in die krise
reingerutscht hat dann muss er den
posten verlieren auch wenn er noch nicht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]